نعم هذه هزات ارتداديه ما زالت تضرب
تحديد المناطق الجنوبيه وليس تركيا
[موسيقى]
هي نتيجه الانزالين
الذين ضربات كهرمان مرعش يوم امس الاول
بقوه 7.7 والثاني بقوه 7.6 لذلك الهزات
الارتجاجيه لم تتوقف وهي تثير الرعب حقيقه
في نفوس سكان هذه المنطقه وايضا تزيد تزيد
قلق السلطات التركيه مع ان الهزات
الاعتزابيه تؤدي الى انهيار مزيد من
المباني التي تصنعت نوعا ما بسبب الزلزال
مع استمرار الهزات الاعتزابيه هذا يعني ان
المزيد من المباني
ستسقط وهذا ما دفع السلطات تركيا الصباح
امس بعد الزلزال مباشره الى تعبير السكان
من عدم العوده الى منازلهم التي تصدعت او
تشققت والبقاء اما في مراكز او في اماكن
مفتوحه هذا طبعا ايضا ان هذه الهزات
الاعتداديه
تعرق العمل
طرق الطوارئ والكوارث لذلك يعني اليوم
عمليه الوصول الى الناجين او
رفع الانقاب هي عمليه معقده نوعا ما انا
امام هذه عمليه تحديات عديده منها
الهزات الاقتصاديه ايضا منها تعطل الطرق
في بعض المناطق منها ايضا الضغوط المناصيه
السيئه والثلوج التي تسقط في غزاره في بعض
المناطق في مناطقها في غازي عنتاب
وايضا في كهرمان مرعش كل هذه الظروف
الجويه السيئه ايضا اضافه الى العوامل
السابقه
وعرقل في بعض الاحيان العمل واحيانا اخرى
تعيق وصول الفرق الانقاذ او طواقم الانقاذ
الى الاماكن المحدده في الوقت المناسب